[Music]
what's the face of hard news CNN's now
the but of America's jokes the latest
oddity Chris Cuomo conspires over
President Trump's appearance yes he
looks exactly the same since he became
president and that can't be good look at
presidents when they come in and when
they leave I mean come on look at
Clinton's hair when white George W Bush
looks like you got a beatdown Obama
looks like his own grandfather I mean
look at it I mean this is a very hard
job because of the stress that they
carry with them now let's look at this
president it's been almost three years
since Trump won the presidency it looks
exactly the same his hair is like you
know I don't know what's going on with
that but he may do things that
presidents in the past haven't done to
augment their physical reality but it
could also be that he doesn't care the
way others have only on the clown news
network and an anchor wonder if the
president is augmenting his physical
reality in other words what the hell
does this mean but I guess this they've
run out of ways to say Trump is crazy
they moved on to he somehow has
magically stopped the aging process I
don't know about you but maybe I'd leave
the paranormal analysis to experts in
crop circles meanwhile you got to wonder
how much CNN pays for this political
analysis I am the chosen one he says and
that comes after the president retweeted
a conspiracy theorist radio host who
said that he is like the second coming
so what what do you make of all this
maybe his mommy should have told him she
loved him a little bit more I don't know
you know it's hard it's just it's hard
you know hard to know someone has a
future in online psychology so Gloria
you did Trump just now tell us why Chris
Cuomo was so angry but talk about never
aging she looks great the only thing
that gets old is her stick but only CNN
could frame not aging as a bad thing
imagine Trump was showing his age Cuomo
toast would say the job is wearing him
down so much it's now a serious threat
to the survival of our republic so
no such luck Trump looks the same as he
did when he took office too bad you
can't say the same for CNN Cuomo takes
one more toast you like that it's a good
one Greg is it really I think so okay
then I'll keep it that's right if you
were married to Milania yes probably
have that youthful look to are you
saying something about my wife no I'm
just it's a peace and prosperity glow
there's no there's no recession it's not
aging him that bad also you don't really
see the difference you got to put Trump
2016 and Trump 2024 then maybe you could
do a side by something when he runs
that's what he think is the beginning of
his third term exactly maybe 2028 and
also you know when Trump wakes up in the
morning you hear he doesn't even
remember what happened the rest the next
day or the day before because he doesn't
let and negativity weigh him down the
way an all-pro NFL quarterback that's
how they Scout these guys you want a guy
that gets burned for a 50-yard pass next
snap he's still up there with swagger
forgot about the last play and still is
talking trash even that's Donald Trump
you know unlike Gloria you should get an
award for analysis because in fact Trump
gets burned on every play it doesn't
seem to matter and then when he gets
embarrassed and the media reports on it
you guys say ah the media is terrible
why are they saying that he was talked
about Greenland and then said oh why
would anybody call that absurd buying
Greenland you know Truman had a
first-rate Democrat I believe there's no
recession the economy is great open I'm
thinking about tax cuts and drop out why
don't you cut rates phasing part of this
is they would rather have the president
act like Muller who doesn't remember or
know anything about what he was working
out for the last two years or Joe Biden
who doesn't know the difference between
truth and facts I mean that's what they
want they want if someone is a certain
age they should just be stupid here's
the bottom line with the 800 points
everybody went nuts a we're going to
race
and that's it and you and I both know
that it's the animal instincts that
decide how we go forward in the economy
800 points we came back immediately all
right so everything is fine in terms of
the economy in terms of our being safe I
mean they just wanted to be crazy and
he's not because he's used to stress
he's not a politician he didn't come up
these and way the way the rest of them
got one facet he points out often is he
doesn't drink doesn't smoke yes I think
that's the point cuz yeah because like
people who everybody I know who doesn't
drink has too much energy for me right
and that's a lot for you for a no it's
like my friends you don't drink are
they're just overpowering with energy I
agree
well it's his problem is he doesn't
sleep either he's tweeting on the job
doesn't need to do it that's the big
point you could be playing golf and a
million places you raise a good point
thank you think do you think if he were
a woman like I kind of did with Gloria
just you know how this is relevant to
the performance that he's doing in the
out of work that he's doing in the White
House but I will say the thought has
crossed my mind
it has he has not you know we'd go back
to the Bush years or bombers and the
presidents do age they change over time
Scott however just for fun for this
segment I went back and looked at say
for example that Oprah interview in 1988
he hasn't changed much at all I mean his
physical appearance is what was the
doctor's note he said he was the the
healthiest man on earth yeah
okay so doctor's orders yeah I mean I
think you gotta listen to medical
profession there's also a correlation I
mean it's not caught there's a decade
where you tend to age in a decade like
like Obama no Obama that's when you go
grey was at the same time he was
president right so it wasn't like it was
the presidency remember when there was
that conspiracy theory about the wife
that it was in fact not Melania but a
body double right you
thing has provided a potty double for
truck yeah what guy will say Cuomo is
right about the observation though he is
right this is a comatose on the toes yes
yeah all right